I think some of
the damage I did
is probably permanent as far
as like an enlarged heart.
Yeah.
I don't want to go
back and bodybuild.
I'm not looking for that.
I'm looking for how
long can I live, right?
I mean if you look around
this office, who's here?
It's old man.
It's like why am I here?
I'm freaking 37.
I mean something's wrong, right?
Jeff has been under the
care of a cardiologist
for the past year.
Ever since doctors treating
his steroid infection also
discovered signs
of heart failure.
So, Doctor, because
Jeff took testosterone
for so many years--
Right.
Now his body doesn't
produce it naturally.
And he actually has to take
testosterone to stay healthy.
Right.
This is the unfortunate irony
for guys that are looking
to become superhuman per say.
They end up in a
point where, again,
they obliterate their
body's own ability
to produce testosterone.
Today, Jeff will be getting
the results to see if his heart
has bounced back to normal.
So there's two
main things that we
are evaluating with that echo.
One is your systolic
function which
is the squeezing function.
And that was the one that
was mildly reduced last time
you were here.
That actually does not look
significantly different.
OK.
So it still looks a
little bit sluggish.
Yep.
But there's another
parameter that we
look at which is the relaxation
function of the heart.
Right.
And that was also quite
abnormal last time you
got here.
That looks significantly better.
OK.
You know we're not at the point
where I'd say your heart looks
normal, unfortunately.
Right.
I think you should sort of
get your mind around the fact
that you're probably going to
be on long term medication.
I worry about Jeff's longevity.
His heart actually hasn't
bounced back to normal.
And the longer we see it, that
sort of suggests that something
permanent has happened there.
And if he started
taking steroids again?
Not a good idea.
We heard from a lot of
people that say that there
is a safe way of doing this.
The people that have
gotten hurt is because they
didn't know what
they were doing,
and they were taking
too much, or--
but there is actually
a safe way to do this.
Right.
What do you think?
I think those people
are kidding themselves.
The best data that we
have are autopsy studies.
That means someone died.
Jeff, frankly, is lucky.
There's lots and
lots of case reports
of young guys
having heart attacks
and having strokes,
sudden death.
So your first symptom is dying.